This is Grayson.
This is my third-grade friend.
We've gone through the major life moments together:...
...traveling to the Europe, going through puberty.
We went to boarding school so it got really weird.
People do bizarre things like run through the dining hall completely naked during dinner.
We were hanging out and both of our girlfriends were out of town...
...and it was a Saturday night, so we're like, "We're men, let's do things, let's be crazy."
And so the extent of our craziness was eating banana bread...
...and that was where our craziness ended.
It was banana bread and taking photos of ourselves in bathrobes to send to our girlfriends...
...saying we miss them because we're pathetic.
We're really fortunate they're not jealous people because I think at times,...
...Grayson and I are better boyfriends to each other than we are to them.
What are we gonna do today, Grayson?
It is your birthday.
We already had a Belgian waffle with strawberries and whipped cream this morning.
It was lovely.
We're gonna be fat kids together.
And that's really what any relationship is based off,...
...of this how fat you can be in front of the other person without feeling bad about yourself.
It works out really well too 'cause we have the same sunglasses...
...so anytime I lose mine I can steal his and it's wonderful.
So every day it's my birthday even though today is his.